Now, the only thing that we wanted to
change with this new equation was to plug
in the symbols square and triangle for the
words that we had before. So, that means
that we only want to change what's right
here and what's right here. That means
that we can keep the numbers that are
already in the equation in the same
places. So let's just go ahead and bubble
those in. Our substitution rule said that
we can replace money Grant has left with a
square and number of months with a
triangle, so let's bubble those in. Money
Grant has left comes first so that means
that this square comes first And number of
months comes very last. So that means, the
triangle, comes at the end. So now, our
equation reads, square = $3,000,000 -
$100,000 times triangle.